Good morning, Hank. It's Monday March 29th 2010.
It's tax season, which means that I must once again for the 32nd consecutive year,
report to the Internal Revenue Service that I have failed to garner any fishing boat proceeds.
French the Llama!
Fishing boat proceeds are the unicorns of my tax return.
And now, Hank, having alienated all our new viewers,
I begin the video.
So Hank, I have a bad habit of googling myself
--Hello Holden Caulfield Hat, how did you get here?--
So the other day, I was googling myself,
and I discovered something absolutely incredibly--
Wait, wait, wait,
I have something important to discuss,
which is that in a few days,
I have a book coming out that I co-wrote with David Levithan
and we are going on tour
and some of the events on the tour are ticketed, others are not,
to find out if yours is ticketed, go to the link in the dooblydoo.
Right Hank, so I discovered something pretty incredible,
and it wasn't that there is a guy named John Green who is one of The Four Horsemen Of Sasquatchery.
That I already knew
because one time I wrote an article for Mental Floss Magazine
in which I talked about the fact that Bigfoot is, you know, fictional
and I totally got a letter from famous Bigfoot apologist,
John Green,
who said my anti-Bigfoot propaganda
was besmirching the good name of John Greens everywhere.
Right so that is not what I discovered.
What I discovered
--This is kind of annoying.
The tassel!
How did Holden deal with the tassel?--
What I discovered is that a line I wrote years ago in my book,
An Abundance Of Katherines, has kind of gone viral on Twitter.
It's been tweeted more than 10,000 times.
The line is "Che senso ha la vita se almeno non provi a fare qualcosa di significativo?".
I don't speak Italian.
The line is,
"What is the point of being alive
if you don't at least try to do something remarkable?
Which I will admit I did write in this book,
but as anyone who's read it knows,
I was kidding.
That's something Colin Singleton,
the main character of the book - he's kind of a child prodigy,
says at the beginning of the book
and he must spend the entire book learning it's...
bull.
I don't know how it looks on the screen there on YouTube,
but in the Viewfinder,
It looks a little bit like a lady hat
but I promise it is not,
it is the actual replica
the actual replica
of a hat worn by
a fictional character in a novel.
Anyway, Hank,
this phenomenon, it seems to me, is near universal in the internet age,
which is that instead of people being misquoted,
that they are miscontextualized.
It's impossible to pull a line or a sentence or even a chapter from a book
and understand the meaning of that section
Because, as much as it pains us in this soundbite, twittering world,
text means nothing without its context.
For instance, Holden Caulfield's red hunting cap doesn't really make any sense
until you have the context telling you that it's the same color as his dead brother's hair.
Look, she's wearing a hat.
It's not a metaphor.
I just thought it was funny.
Anyway, Hank, the whole thing made me think about something.
Maybe our favorite quotations say more about us
than they say about the stories and people we're quoting.
So Nerdfighters,
what's your favorite quote?
Leave it down below in comments,
and then let's think about what that says about us.
I mean, how did Holden Caulfield deal with the tassel issue?
Is that ever covered in the text?
My favorite quote of the moment is from Robert Frost:
"The only way out
is through."
I don't know what that says about me, but I'm sure you'll tell me in comments.
And then we'll all tell each other what our quote says about each other.
Okay,
gotta get rid of this tassel, so annoying.
Hank, I'll see you on Wednesday
From some angles, it's a lady hat,
and then from some angles, it's like,
"It's-a me Mario!"